- [Assaf] Alright.
Hi everybody and welcome to
the Enhance Contact Center
with Salesforce and AWS.
Really excited to be here today.
My name is Assaf Ben-Gur
and I'm the product lead
for Salesforce Channels
and Contact Centers and I'm
honored to be joined by Marc.
- Hey everybody, Marc Rudkowski.
I'm a principal product
manager for Amazon Connect.
Been with Connect since we
launched it back in 2017.
You know, we're a lightning talk,
so we've got less than 20 minutes.
So I've got the timer to get going.
We've got about 19 minutes
left, so we're gonna go
through this as, as best we can
'cause we've gotta demo the
show as well as part of this.
So, let's go.
- Sounds like a plan.
Before we start, we wanna share
with you the forward-looking statement.
Don't make any purchase decisions based
on non-generally available product.
Let's start a little
bit with the challenge
of contact centers today.
When your customers phone in
today, they expect your agents
to be super knowledgeable
about who they are, what type
of relationship they have with you.
They expect them to be super knowledgeable
and experts in solving
the issue that they have.
Instead, the experience they're
getting is being put on hold
because your agent is trying
to stitch the customer
profile in real time
behind the scenes.
And when they're ready to action
and resolve the issue that
they called about, they need
to swivel between multiple systems.
We keep hearing three things
from contact center leaders today.
They want to boost agent productivity
with high customer satisfaction.
They want to reduce operating costs
because it's still considered
a heavy cost center
for the company.
And now more than ever, they want
to actively participate
in growing the top line
for the company.
They want an active role
in growing the revenue
for the company.
So after resolving the
customer issue, they want
to free up their agents to
quickly focus on upselling
and cross-selling.
And AI, specifically generative
and addressing experiences.
Exactly the technology
that can help you transform
your contact centers.
It's intuitive, it's smarter, it's faster,
it's everything we need
to take the contact
centers to the next level,
but it's not easy.
We know a lot of those projects just fail.
You can't just take AI and
just slap it on your data
and on your channels and hope for good.
Remember that agent that go
and stitch your customer
profile because it's all over?
Your data is all over.
Your channels completely disconnected,
your call center completely disconnected
from your digital channels.
Your agents can do either telephony
or they can do email or messaging.
They're not versatile.
They're walking off of
totally different systems
and totally different desktops.
And last but not least, AI is the new toy.
Everybody in your company
wants to do something with AI.
Your marketing team is doing
something completely different
from your sales team that
is doing something different
from your servicing team.
And your R&D and product team,
just last week they had
this amazing hackathon
and they came up with
an amazing way using AI
to solve a specific use case.
That single use case amazing,
but the contact center leaders
and the CIO, specifically,
are being left with a lot
of like point solutions
completely fragmented across.
And this is exactly where Salesforce
and Amazon Connect came together
to bring you an experience,
come taking channels
natively from Salesforce,
all bring them over from Amazon
Connect and give your agents
and your contact center
experience one unified, cohesive,
standardized way to manage
everything customer interaction
in one single space.
From agentic self-service portals
to channels like WhatsApp,
chat, email, voice studies
coming in from Amazon Connect,
Apple messaging for
business line for Japan.
We have all the channels you need in order
to standardize all this experience
throughout the customer lifecycle journey.
And all those channels are
agent force, AI agent ready.
The same agent force builder helps you
to build this logic in one
place and then distribute it
and attach it to any
channel that you need.
You need a channel to completely automate
your email interaction?
Just use the same agent.
You need that channel to walk off
of your WhatsApp experience,
your line, your web chat?
That same agent.
And now as of October, thanks to Marc
and Amazon Connect, we have
a fully integrated solution
with Agent Force Voice running on top
of the Amazon Connect voice channel
- And our other channels as well, right?
And so this is where
the key aspect of this
that gives you that optionality
between our platforms, right?
Because we both bring rich capabilities,
we're on the digital engagement
and your voice interactions.
And you know, basically, because that,
we can run, whether
it's using Salesforce's
native agent force agents
or it's using Amazon
Connects AI agents, you have
that flexibility in terms of enabling that
and having the right fit for each
of your use cases in the
contact center and CRM.
- Exactly.
And now that you free up your agents
from focus on like tier one,
FAQ type of interactions,
they have a lot more bandwidth
to focus on more eye value interactions.
Really focus on the interactions
where you need a human touch.
You need them for dealing with escalation.
Those like more of the
complex type of experiences.
And this is where all the
assistive AI capabilities come in.
Things like service replies
attached to your email channel,
grounded by your knowledge.
That same email reply application
and service reply application apply
to your messaging channels,
your WhatsApp, your web chat,
your Apple business for messaging.
At the end of the call,
you wanna reduce that wrap up time.
Call summarization help you
to reduce minutes out of it
so you can free up your human agent
to focus on the next interaction.
And last but not least is your supervisor.
It's a whole new world
for your supervisors.
Yesterday, they just
manage just the labor,
human labor workforce.
Now they need to manage
all those AI agents.
This is why we, our omni
supervisor to be command center
for service, really bring in a cockpit,
one single unified
workplace that allow you
to manage both your human
agents and your AI agents.
So your supervisor can
get alerts in real time
and flag raise based on conversations
that their AI agents are driving,
and then be able to listen in
and interject where needed.
But there's so much more.
I know Marc, you guys have been busy
in the last nine months,
like building the next wave of innovation.
- Yeah, so let me talk a little bit
in terms of what we've
actually announced this week
and I'll talk a little bit
in terms of the integration
that we have with
Salesforce Contact Center
with Amazon Connect.
Yeah, thank you for the clicker.
So back in March, we announced
and launched Salesforce Contact
Center with Amazon Connect.
I know that's a mouthful.
So for the rest of the presentation,
you gonna hear me use the term SCCAC
'cause it's a lot easier to
say from that perspective.
Back in March when we
announced and launched this,
essentially what it was,
was we worked super
closely with Salesforce
and we saw a lot of success that we had
with Agent Force Voice in terms
of enabling that with a lot
of our core contact centers.
But what customers really wanted was
they wanted additional channels,
they wanted additional
Connect capabilities
that were unified as part
of Agent Force Voice.
So when we released this in March,
we were actually the first contact center
to implement Bring Your Own Chat,
which essentially takes our native chat
and it integrated with
Salesforce's chat capabilities.
So the advantage of that is
that when you're in Connect
and you're in our IVR experience,
you can leverage our voice,
you can leverage our native chat.
But when it gets to the
point of actually escalating
to an agent, we actually then send it in
through Salesforce chat UX,
and it essentially pops up
as a native Salesforce chat
within Agent Force Voice.
So the advantage of that is
from an agent perspective,
whether they're using Salesforce chat
or our native chat, it looks the same.
You get that deep rich
integration across the capability.
So for example, being able
to have those pre-configured
replies, right,
to be able to answer, you
know, those customer inquiries
that are often happening
and giving agents shortcut
to quickly answer questions.
We can enable that really
easily and natively
within Salesforce as part of that.
The other aspect of that of
what we announced this week is
now what we started to
do is really then start
to expand additional Connect capabilities.
So, you probably heard a lot this week
with Connect is us announcing
our native AI agents
integrated as part of Connect.
And part of that is really giving you
out-of-the-box AI agents
that you can start
to leverage both from a
self-service perspective as well
as an agent assist perspective.
So what we announced this week is,
essentially, the next version
of SCCAC, which now allows you
to add agent assist capabilities
with Connect AI agents natively
within Agent Force Voice.
So the advantage of that now
is essentially, you know,
from a self-service perspective,
whether using our voice
or our chat channels,
you can have that rich AI agent experience
and then hand all of that
interaction, you know,
through the Agent Force Voice experience.
And then as the agent
is trying to continue
to resolve the issue with that context.
For example,
they could be plugging into
Salesforce knowledge base,
you know, for getting all
the SOPs and recommendations.
And essentially as they go through that,
and I'll show a demo of
this in a little bit,
have that interaction, you
know, walk through that
and then give the agent the, essentially,
the right recommendations
to solve that issue
as quickly as possible.
Once the chat or the voice
call is over, at that point,
give them the summary of the
interaction that they have
so they can quickly update
the Salesforce case to ensure
that, you know, there is,
as Assaf mentioned earlier,
like saving often minutes
right from the agent's time
in terms of improving
their overall productivity
to not only solve the issue
but then update the issue
from an after call work perspective.
And what you see here
is you see, you know,
we've got quite a rich roadmap
in terms of capabilities
that we've recently announced
in terms of overall sets
of features.
You know, what I just
talked about here was
essentially our agent assist
and summarization capabilities.
I'll do a demo of that in a few minutes.
What's that?
Yeah.
Okay, just so.
And then real time transcription
for additional languages.
So back at Dreamforce,
Salesforce announced
the additional support.
So that runs a lot on our
core underlying capabilities
like Amazon Transcribe
and it really talks to the
global capabilities that we have
as a better together story.
So Connect brings that particularly
around our telephony
capabilities as global telephony.
We bring that at scale in
terms of managed telephony
across the entire world.
And part of that is
really now with, you know,
with Salesforce from an agent experience,
you get all the language support
around all of that as well.
So again, we are truly a
global solution in terms
of all the capabilities that you get
between Salesforce and Amazon Connect.
We had also announced Agent
Force Voice with Amazon Connect.
So in terms of supporting
third party voice experiences,
we now enable that as part
of Amazon Connect as well.
And then finally, from a
workforce management perspective,
if you're using our chat
and our voice capabilities,
you can leverage our workforce management
or FCS capabilities, for capacity planning
and scheduling capabilities
natively within Connect.
And from a roadmap
perspective, we're working
with Salesforce to start
to support their channels
in the future as well.
So again, we continue...
You can see we continue to
evolve the overall capabilities
and integration between the two in terms
of overall feature sets and just richer
and richer integrations overall.
So, let's jump into a demo.
Let's see, I'm looking at my
clock, I got eight minutes
and 34 seconds,
- Plenty.
so plenty of time here.
So, let's see if we can
go through the demo.
Alright, perfect.
And so this is a bit
of a click through demo
because nobody trusts me doing live demos,
especially on stage when
I've only got 20 minutes
to walk through that.
Actually less than
that, eight minutes now.
So, we've got, so just to
set up some background.
So this is AnyCompany.
It's an energy company use case
that we talked through here.
We've got Nikki as the customer.
She's coming in, she has a
problem with her generator,
and we're gonna help her,
basically solve that issue
with, you see, within a few clicks
overall from that perspective.
So the chat comes in.
Essentially what you see here is...
Actually, this is always
the challenge here.
There we go.
And so we have the chat
here with Nikki, you know,
and she say, "Doc, thank
you for contacting us."
Now again, this is, for the sake of speed,
we're doing a fairly simple use case here.
But you can imagine this
could be using, you know,
one of our AI agents.
It could be using Agent Force
agents in terms of creating
that interaction,
that self-service experience
in terms of overall
capabilities around that.
You know, once we escalate to an agent,
which is what we're gonna show here,
essentially, all the contacts of
that iteration gets handed
over to Nikki is part of that.
So essentially at this
point, the chat comes in,
Nikki gets this essentially
omni item in terms of being able
to answer the chat as part of that.
This is her dashboard by the way.
So she has a rich dashboard
in terms of seeing
how she's doing overall or across her day.
Great, click on that.
And now, at this point, you see the chat,
the messaging window.
Again, you can see it's,
if you're familiar with
Salesforce's chat window,
it looks very, it's similar.
It's identical to that in terms
of that overall interaction.
They're having that interaction
from that perspective.
Now, a few clicks later, you
know, she's asking essentially,
you know, "I need guidance
on a generator installation,
can you please help?"
Sure, right?
So at this point in real time,
the Connect HAI agent,
which is also hooked up
to a Salesforce knowledge base,
is now understanding the intent
and the ask that's happening
as part of the chat.
And as part of that,
it's now going to provide a
recommendation back to the agent
where the agent can then,
you know, quickly read that,
and then provide that guidance
back to Nikki in terms
of solving this overall generator issue.
In addition to that, it's
also gonna provide the links
to the sources.
So if the agent, you
know, wants to, again,
with a human in the middle,
being able to look at in terms
of the sources of that data
and do a little bit
deeper research if needed,
you know, they can understand where
that information's coming
from, which is great.
They can also search as well.
So, if it doesn't quite meet
in terms of what they're looking for
in terms of a recommendation,
they can easily there
and continue to go search
through the knowledge base
for additional answers
as part of that.
So great, the agent responds,
you know, as part of
that interaction, and then
we solve Nikki's problem.
And then at the end, you see that there up
in the upper right corner is
the Amazon Connect summarization.
So now we've taken that
end to end interaction
that have from our chat perspective,
we've summarized that,
and then essentially,
we can update the case,
you know, within a few clicks,
and, you know, we've solved
the overall issue again.
So, you can see here
that we've taken the native
Amazon Connect capabilities
and we've integrated
into the Salesforce Agent
Force Voice experience
and really providing
that overall unified experience overall.
- [Assaf] So Marc, the agents don't need
to log in into multiple systems?
The agent just walk off of that
one single unified desktop?
- [Marc] Exactly, exactly.
So, we've removed a lot of
the heavy lifting, right,
that our customers will
have to do in terms
of integrating these capabilities.
And we've made it from an
out-of-the-box perspective,
simple, easy to set up,
configure, and start to enable.
- [Assaf] Perfect.
- [Marc] All right, so let's switch back
to the presentation.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
Alright.
So some of the things here
to note here too is Amazon
Connect, we have tens
of thousands of customers soaring
more than 16 million interactions a day.
So this really talks
to the scale at which Amazon Connects is
leveraged and deployed with.
You can see here the numerous customers
and we have a lot of joint customers
that are also Salesforce
customers that we work so closely,
like Vista, Truist, Air Canada,
are all great examples in terms
of who uses integration today
and have continued to scale
this, you know, overall across,
you know, solving their key
contact center capabilities
and problems that they have overall.
So again, we've seen a lot of success,
you know, from that overall.
And just as a reminder...
Oh, go ahead, did you wanna say something?
- We have just, you know,
thousands of joint customers already,
- Thousands of joint customers today.
- Like growing really, really nicely.
You know, double digit,
almost hitting like 100
million voice call a month.
And this is amazing
number for Amazon Connect
across all customers.
- We are the largest
contact center, right,
in terms of leveraging
this with Salesforce
in terms of the integration
capabilities that we have.
And for those of you that
were in PQ session yesterday,
I brought this up as another reminder.
Last yearm in terms of, you know,
the number of customer interactions
that are using AI, you know,
within using Amazon Connect
to optimize those interactions,
it was about 6 billion a year ago.
We've doubled that now to 12 billion.
So again, it continues to show the fact
that we have used AI from
the beginning with Connect
and we continue to use that journey
and we continue to enable
that natively within Connect,
but also working closely with
our partners like Salesforce
to give you the, those
capabilities as well, right,
from a joint perspective,
better together story
as we work together to continue to evolve,
what is, I'd say, is a very fast,
rapidly changing space
from that perspective,
but it is the number one use
case is the contact center
with AI.
And so, you know, we're here
working together in terms of
how do we best solve your
use cases as end customers
and large enterprises to
make sure that, you know,
we're meeting that to the speed
and capabilities that you need
from an overall contact
center and CRM perspective.
And so with that, I've got two minutes
and 40 seconds, so I
think I did all right,
and with that.
So, you know what, I'll say
we've got our booths here,
so definitely come, you know,
come visit the Salesforce
booth, booth number 739,
I think it's like right over
there from that perspective.
And then come visit the
Amazon Connect booth.
That's hard to miss.
It's that big AWS one
that's right in the middle.
I've got a QR code here as well.
And then obviously,
for those of you who
have your account teams,
feel free to reach out to them.
They can definitely, you know,
in terms of getting you up
to speed on all the capabilities.
Follow me on LinkedIn.
Follow Assaf on LinkedIn.
I posted a bunch of stuff up there as well
so you can take a look
in terms of, you know,
links in terms of how
to get more information
about Agent Force Voice or SCCAC, right.
We've got all that information up there
and obviously, we're here as well,
so, happy to have the conversation
and talk some about it.
- And regardless of what
footprint they have, right?
Like whether they have other
point solutions that they want
to go and transform
and take it to the next stage
potentially with Salesforce
and Amazon Connect, or
whether you already invested
in Amazon Connect channels or you want
to evaluate Salesforce channels
and bring it all along.
We have the solution for you.
We've built it in a
modular way that can build,
bring all this modularity
and all these components
together meaningfully
for your agent and supervisor.
So we're looking forward
for any next steps here.
- Great.
And with that, we thank you everybody
for attending today, and I
did it with a minute left.
So thanks everybody.
Have a good rest of your day.